[Musique]
champion du monde c'est monde est un
passement de jambes fait un festin
tirant le luxe et la pièce lamy le
terrain comme andrés iniesta un petit
pont ça fait du mal chez nous c'est vrai
ce que les finales bas copine me couche
toulouse limaille parce que je suis beau
gosse comme antoine de saint-exupéry
c'est précis j'ai l'impression que tu
apprécies comme tout petit dans la tc on
m'appelait leonardo dicaprio et ouais
mais si chaque missile m'appeler mais si
[Musique]
vous l'avez fait le coup du foulard
j'en ai marre de cacher cette énorme
secret
je ne connais rien au foot je fais
semble encore être acceptée à certains
moments je crie en jeu quand on dit et
pour qui je dis les bleus pour moi une
bicyclette c'est avant tout un moyen de
transport très ingénieux
je vois très bien qu'ils aient zidane
non je suis pas fou
j'vois un peu moi qui y ai fait lire
c'est un peu flou
je vois très bien qu'ils n'aient
cristiano ronaldo un brésilien qui
aujourd'hui est un peu gros et fall plus
calme
football
je veux juste crié but chaque fois qu'on
marque ago
je veux crier 2
il
p
je veux juste crié but si tout comme moi
tu as déjà offert un maillot avec une
faute d'orthographe l'eau qui tantôt
sache que tu n'es pas seul
si tout comme moi on a proposé de faire
un five tu pensais que c'était faire un
check qui assure grave sache que tu n'es
pas seul
non non on voit très bien qui est motard
mais pas fou on voit moins bien qui est
au vent c'est un peu flou on sait très
bien ce qu'est une l2
dijon c'est ce qui permet de voler un
pigeon a plus qu'à
en fout
je suis
ce crime
chaque fois qu'on m'a dit
me crier but
je vivais
si tu connais rien au foot sache qu'on
est
toi
un pouvoir
fort des bons joueurs si tu ne connais
rien au foot sache qu'on
[Musique]
g
réussi
il faudrait faire froid vent
pas d'autres analysés la saison de
golden moustache c'est fini on se
retrouve l'année prochaine mais on va
faire plein de trucs cool pour cette
coupe du monde cliquer sur le macaron
pour tout voir et rejoindre le golden
moustache football club
sinon si tu en as rien à faire du foot
pendant l'été il ya une série de ouf qui
arrive mais je peux pas trop en parler
enfin ce que je peux dire c'est qu'à
trône dedans non invasive jan palach
déjà 3 10